ich möchte heute mit ihnen über die
impfpflicht drehen das ist das thema was
mir schon seit gestern sehr bewegt ich
bin fürs impfen aber gegen die
impfpflicht auch christian lindner und
olaf scholz beschlossen lange zeit die
impfpflicht rigoros aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nein keine impfpflicht aber natürlich
ist die priorität bei der impfung müssen
werben dass menschen auch die zweite
impfung in anspruch nehmen ich finde es
wäre falsch wenn jetzt eine debatte
beginnt über
pflichten und ähnliches
jetzt hat es sich gedreht weit kann es
ja olaf stolz verkündete bei bild das er
für die impfpflicht sei politik kann
sich irren aber in diesem fall ist der
vertrauensverlust immens und olaf scholz
hat für mich seine glaubwürdigkeit
verspielt für mich ist die impfpflicht
konträr zur freiheit denn auch wenn eine
höhere impfquote die pandemie
zurückdenke drängen kann was sie kann
bedeutet die impfpflicht zunächst dass
der staat den menschen einen
medizinischen eingriff verordnet und so
ihre körperliche unversehrtheit und
entscheidungsfreiheit eingreift das darf
nicht sein für mich habe ich schon
länger den eindruck er ist den
politikern doch gar nicht mehr nur ums
infektions und gesundheitsschutz
geschehen geht sondern vor allem wollen
sie kings druck ausüben die politik
braucht einen sündenbock für waren ist
zu unvernünftigen jetzt sind es die
ungeimpften
selbstverständlich wäre eine höhere
impfquote besser eine neue studie von
berliner und erfordern vorstand zeigt
dass drei viertel der korona infektion
in deutschland von ungeimpften ausgelöst
werden wir dürfen nicht aufgeben für
eine höhere importe zu kämpfen aber mit
aufklärung und positiven anreizen nicht
mit hemmungslosen druck und stellte
schon jetzt werden millionen menschen in
unserem land ausgegrenzt wenn nicht
geimpft ist darf nicht mehr in
restaurants nicht auf die
weihnachtsmärkte und nichts ins
schwimmbad in baden-württemberg dürfen
ungewünschte nicht einmal mehr in die
universität die impfpflicht würde diesen
zustand auf die spitze treiben die
begründung der befürworter impfpflicht
sei freiheit bedeutet viele menschen in
diesem land sehr große unfreiheit druck
und zwang deshalb bin ich gegen die
impfpflicht und hoffe darauf dass die
mehrheit der bundestagsabgeordneten
weiter gegen dann stimmen ein thema der
öffentlichen runde ja liebe leser das
ist ja ein ziemlich hartes und sehr
interessantes statement von dir ich
glaube dass bewegt uns alle gerade ganz
massiv ich stimme dir zum teil zu aber
zum teil stimme ich dir auch nicht zu
ich finde es richtig dass der druck auf
die ungeimpften ein stück weit steigt
denn es ist doch auch war das weil es so
viele ungeimpfte gibt wir in der lage
sind in der wir eben sind nämlich dass
es wieder ein crooner winter geben wird
dass ein großteil der bevölkerung der ja
nun mittlerweile geimpft ist zum glück
geimpft ist
nicht so frei leben kann wie er möchte
aber auf der anderen seite ich sagte
schon stimme ich dir auch zu heute hat
otto schily einen sehr interessanten
gastbeitrag geschrieben und er sagt die
impfpflicht sei ich zitiere das eine
verfassungswidrige anmaßung des staates
das finde ich schon interessant denn ich
erinnere mich daran einmal gelernt zu
haben wenn man zum arzt geht und dort
wird dann eigentlich vorgenommen dann
ist der die jure erstmal eine
körperverletzung und nur in dem ich zu
dem arzt sage ich möchte dass dieser
eingriff vorgenommen wird ich bin damit
einverstanden was natürlich bei jedem
von uns vorliegt sonst wäre man ja gar
nicht zum arzt gegangen wird das ganze
sozusagen in ordnung und das sich nun
der staat dazu aufschwingen zu sagen du
musst diesen eingriff vornehmen lassen
das kann ich gut verstehen dass du das
höchst problematisch findet die zeit ist
natürlich auch schwierig nicht krieg
heute eine mail von jemandem junge frau
die sagt sie hat viereinhalb stunden die
haben alexa das ist ein einkaufscenter
hier am alexanderplatz angestanden in
ganz berlin christo überhaupt gar keinen
termin
ja der tod im stoff kommt erst noch
viele warten darauf dass heißt ich finde
die debatte kommt zur unzeit und ich bin
selbst davon auch nicht überzeugt ich
tue mir auch schwer ziemlich auch sehr
schwer einer impfpflicht zuzustimmen
finde aber ein punkt den wir glaube ich
schon betrachten müssen wenn es darum
geht was machen wir mit den vielen
vielen ungeimpften und ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass auch ungeimpfte die ja für
viele kosten verantwortlich sind ob es
jetzt die intensiv medizin betreuung ist
wie auch immer schon irgendwie dafür
auch zur kasse gebeten werden müssen auf
welche art auch immer aber wenn man sich
einmal vorstellen man fährt auf der
autobahn kein tempolimit natürlich und
verursacht einen unfall dann würde man
auch ganz klar sein natürlich der der
den unfall verursacht der muss irgendwie
für die kosten der entstehen aufkommen
und es kann da jeder fahren wie er will
und kann langsam fahren kann schnell
fahren das ist ja ein bisschen mit dem
thema impfen ähnlich kann mich impfen
lassen was ich auch sehr begrüßen würde
ich muss ist nicht und würde die
argumente die gerade gefallen sind
durchaus da sehr unterstützen aber
trotzdem sehen wir ja dass die
ungeimpften dieses system hier zum teil
sehr stark belasten und die frage ist
müssen eigentlich alle geimpften die
kosten getragen oder ist das etwas was
die geimpft die ungeimpften schon
übernehmen soll und da glaube ich müssen
wir auch eine debatte darüber führen was
ist eigentlich mit denen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen aus gut
nachvollziehbaren gründen aber der
allgemeinheit extreme kosten auf lassen
hier möchte ich ganz kurz ein haken jan
weil es ist ja so die impfpflicht soll
dazu führen dass die impfquote steigt ja
die menschen werden nicht zwangsgeld wie
festgeld und geimpft sondern sie werden
sanktionen bekommen ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt nicht dass durch die impfpflicht
die impfquote steigen wird ich glaube
sogar dass menschen er dann die bußen
die dann kommen werden das weiß man
nicht hinnehmen werden aus zwei gründen
wenn ich mir den osten und den westen
anschauen aktuell die bundesländer im
osten ist eigentlich die impfquote immer
höher als im westen jetzt ist aber im
osten die impfquote niedriger auch bei
der grippeimpfung haben sie eigentlich
höhere impfquote das problem ist also
für mich ganz klar hier wir haben es mit
diesem ganzen druck eigentlich geschafft
dass die impfbereitschaft sinkt und wenn
man menschen immer mehr in die ecke
gedrängt dann steigt in meinen augen
nicht die bereitschaft ich finde die
politik hat noch nicht alles dafür getan
aufzuklären und den menschen mit am
besten auf dem silbertablett die impfung
hin zu reichen ich finde es ist jetzt zu
früh eine impfpflicht zu machen ich
glaube aufklärung würde mehr dafür
sorgen und vielleicht auch wirklich dass
so etwas nicht passt aber abbrechen mit
mit ihrer bundesräte natürlich denn ist
zum teil auch ein eingeständnis mit dem
corona management auch der länder und
vielen mehr andere länder israel und so
haben ja gezeigt dass es schneller geht
frau schenk ich teile die argumente es
gibt drei gruppen er kekulé hat das mal
auf den punkt gebracht es gibt eine
gruppe 5 bis 10 prozent die glauben will
gates pflanzt uns hier irgendwas ein die
können sie mir überzeugen dann gibt es
zwei gruppen ein seismograph ist oder e
mail account kann man vielleicht beide
gleich groß sehen die eine gruppe die
informieren sich gar nicht über
zeitungen die schauen auch kein fernseh
deren horizont ist der nachbar ist die
familie vielleicht auch eine echo kammer
bei facebook wo man den ganzen tag nur
die gleichen argument hört und deswegen
gebe ich ihnen recht wir müssen das
viele niederschwelliger machen wir
können nicht nur aufklären sie machen
das richtig um viertel nach acht in der
sendung kann auch nicht sein dass markus
lanz nur um halb zwölf aufklärt oder
eigentlich müsste es in allen deutschen
programm viertel nach acht bis zur rtl 2
eine aufklärung geben man kann fragen
stellen und vieles mehr das muss jetzt
kommen ja lingemann ihre partei war hier
in der verantwortung mit dem
gesundheitsminister und das nicht erst
seit gestern sondern seit beginn der
pandemie das hätte ich mir schon die
frage warum ist das nicht erfolgt warum
handball die millionenfachen
millionenschweren kampagnen hier
gefahren wurden nicht gewirkt und wenn
die erkenntnisse da sind dass ein teil
der bevölkerung sich nur aus facebook
kann man merkt ihr wissen warum versucht
man nicht in die kammern zu kommen oder
mit den betreibern solche großen
plattformen da entspricht rein technisch
voll problem ist natürlich auch dass die
impfpflicht durch verschiedene politiker
wären einige der äußerung gesehen
natürlich diskreditiert worden ist indem
sie erklärt haben sowas kommt nicht dazu
gehören aber nicht nur die drei die wir
heute gesehen haben eben lindner robert
habeck und oder zwei dazu ja die an das
war bei anderen gesehen aber sondern
auch natürlich auch hier einsparen wenn
es kein falscher clip war die nicht mehr
gesehen habe hat er sogar sein wort
gegeben vor dem bundestag das kann
endlich kommt auch die bundeskanzlerin
wird mit diesen worten ähnlich zitiert
das heißt in dem ich natürlich vor der
bundestagswahl das muss man doch klar
sagen ausschließen dass du eine
impfpflicht kommt und im nachgang einer
solchen bundestagswahl sagen uns bleibt
gar nichts anderes übrig diskreditiere
ich doch die maßnahmen und da muss man
sagen diesen schuh muss sich politik
allgemein anziehen die solche warnungen
aus ausgeschlagen haben und ja auch
administrativ komplett versagt haben
indem sie impfzentren geschlossen haben
indem sie den im stoff nicht bereit
erklärt haben indem sie uns auch vor
wann war es zwei monaten erklärt haben
aus dem nichts kommt zehn millionen neue
geimpfte da sagte man ja auch hurra wir
haben die herren immunität erreicht aber
es war in wirklichkeit ganz anders also
krasses missmanagement und nicht auf
richtigkeit haben dazu geführt dass wir
jetzt in dieser lage ja ich will das gar
nicht alles abstreiten ich will nur die
länder mit reinnehmen ich finde das
immer schwach dass man es auf eine
person oder ein politiker anfang august
ist israel angefangen zu ostern in
europa auch in deutschland habe ich
nicht ein länderminister gesehen der
gesagt hat ich mache das jetzt und in
der während der bundestagswahl muss man
auch selbstkritisch sagen ich war damit
in der verantwortung ich habe das thema
corona auch nicht hochgezogen das wollte
auch irgendwie gar keiner hören ja auch
das gehört zu wahren für sind auch warum
weil das ist nämlich unpopulär war und
keiner sich das ans bein binden wollen
und wohl einige das sicherlich auch
gesehen habe zur ehrlichkeit der
politikerinnen und politiker das habe in
den letzten monaten auch gehört nicht
nur versprechungen zu machen die sie
jetzt im nachhinein ja gar nicht halten
können sondern eben auch offen zu sagen
es droht uns ein extrem harter winter
und es werden unpopuläre maßnahmen
kommen ich glaube auch gar nicht dass
das im wahlkampf so schädlich gewesen
wäre weil man sich damit eben auch von
den von den parteien oder von jeder
politischen konkurrenz abgesetzt hätte
der das nicht gelingt gelungen ist so
offen zu reden das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt also das sehen wir ja
bis heute was haben wir gehört bis heute
wird uns nicht erklärt warum es denn so
eine impfpflicht geben muss das ist
kommt irgendwo daher am anfang hieß es
doch pustete impft euch dann ist alles
okay dann nur haben ein schönes
weihnachtsfest und dann reden wir
natürlich auch die schöne schöne zeit
gemeinsam das ist nicht erklärt worden